Here, the inverse function is x plus 5 divided by 6. Great thinking, if you
found this inverse function. One way to find the inverse is to switch the x and
y variables. Once we switch x and y, then we can solve for y. So, adding 5 to
both sides, will get x plus 5 equals 6y. Then, we'll divide both sides by six,
to get y equals x plus 5 divided by 6. And remember, our last step is to
replace this y with f inverse of x, since this represents the inverse function.
Now, the other way to reason through this answer is to think about what we did
to x. We multiplied it by 6, and then subtracted 5. So we want to undo this
subtraction of 5, and then the multiplication of 6. We always undo the last
operation we performed. So first, we'll take x and add 5, and then we'll divide
that quantity by 6. We'll do the opposite of multiplying by 6. This also will
give us our inverse function.